[Music]
[Applause]
in the UK one of the most exciting
Network projects is being undertaken
between City Fiber and Vodafone I'm
delighted to be joined by city fiber CEO
Greg mesh Greg thanks for talking to us
today tell us how the projects going
yeah projects going really well right
now it's early stages of course city
fibers almost 7 years old and we've
built infrastructure across 37 cities
and then we signed a strategic
relationship with Vodafone back in late
2017 and then 2018 was about all
mobilizing for that during that process
of course we did it take private so the
company is now owned by two of the
largest infrastructure funds in the
world as well as we raised 1.1 billion
so we now have a real race to get that
in installed and built and deployed it's
early days with the partnership with
Vodafone of course we're an open access
network so anybody can use us but
Vodafone is our anchor across the
consumer section and what we're seeing
in the early stages is delighting us all
first the products working it's
unbelievably reliable and the customers
are buying it and they're delighted with
the service and and for that to happen
so quickly for even Vodafone I think
it's taken them by surprise
now how can a company actually do what
it says it's going to do when I've been
disappointed from the incumbent forever
and I've been told that something
couldn't take place and it's always late
and suddenly a new fresh introduced
comes and says you know we can actually
do this we like doing it it's
pleasurable to us and the result is a
delightful product so it's early days
but we're seeing all evidence that it's
right on it's let's say it's it's it's
suppressed as surprising us all on the
early stages of success so the five
million by 2025 is looking looking good
well it is looking good and the secret
to that is that we have we've
modularized it so it's very difficult to
say I need to build five million homes
but it's not that difficult to say I
have fifty discreet projects
and that's what we're really looking at
we have 50 discrete projects and each
project says this is a city and what we
do is we mark out the boundaries of that
city very defined it and then we know
exactly the number of properties or
premises we need to build on that city
and then we mobilize in a construction
company and then we manage that to
whatever level of productivity that city
can deliver
so we're finding early days again is
that some cities can have us go faster
even though they're smaller than a big
city that has a lot of restrictions on
us for how many roads they can close but
every city has its own productivity per
city and what we're learning now is
we've got 12 in an operating we're now
beginning to look at city 13 14 15 16 17
18 and 20 and we're taking the learnings
of the first twelve cities we're taking
the good construction companies of the
first twelve cities and we were able to
redeploy them and start working with
them in the next cities so I think it's
I think everything that we had proposed
or her Corp postulated about fear fear
theorized this is showing evidence of
working managing in as a discrete unit
city and then letting that productivity
of that city reach its natural level and
then just managing it through its
process is all working so you know I
won't tell you when the five million
fifth million five millionth home will
be connected but I can see it I can see
it happening that's great along that
journey you know what have been some of
the challenges you know what have you
still got ahead of you to overcome do
you think well you know it's not rocket
science I I don't have to launch a
rocket and put a electric car on the top
to demonstrate to everybody that I can
do something that like the incumbent
says can't be done so NASA said nobody
can launch four times the payload at
twenty percent of the cost and SpaceX
held on must prove them wrong the
incumbents been saying nobody can build
a fiber network efficiently and
cost-effectively and we're demonstrating
that not only can we build it quick and
quickly efficiently but we can offer
economic
that will change the industry so along
that we're learning a lot of things
we're learning how to manage
construction companies we're learning
how to manage expectations with
everybody on how we can do this we're
learning how to work with councils right
some councils want us desperately in
there but then they won't give us Road
closing notices to allow us to close the
roads so so we're learning all those
things but I think the real thing that
we're proving is that it can be done and
that you know it's like Brunel said if
you don't have a dream you can't build
the bridge and we had a dream
everybody's now infectious with that
dream to change the UK forever for
better well it's a very exciting journey
Ron thank you very much for talking to
us
[Music]
you